[Music]  i guess  i'm here live that's not i'm not a cat  i can i can see that  [Laughter]  um  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  focus  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  i'm a footballer and i'm gay  i want to inspire and show people that  it's okay to be yourself and play  football  [Applause]  [Music]  brittany as of today  is a free woman  and she's an independent woman  and the rest with her support system  will be up to  [Music]  brittany we now turn our vessels bow  towards the new republic we  therefore present to you  the designee for national hero of  barbados  ambassador robin rihanna fenty may you  continue to shine like a diamond  and bring honor to your nation  [Music]  you